hey Gill and J we hope you guys are
having a wonderful time on your vacation
we are surfing down the Amazon is a
whole lot of fun
we never saw your friendship coming but
now that it's here to stay we have to
admit you guys are the coolest BFFs of
all time you know it will be fun
to go rafting on a jungle River find a
lost civilization or maybe a penguin
we'd love to see some pictures of your
trip once you get back to Oregon oh and
fYI don't eat the berries off every bush
you come across
that's just risky business descendants
three was everything we wanted and more
but we couldn't help but notice a few
loose ends keep watching to find out
which main character from d2 didn't make
it into d3 like mere queen animal side
by side the old hag Audrey didn't waste
any time when it came to getting her
revenge on Mao she turns her into an old
hag and went on her way but Audrey's
spell went away when now across the
barrier I'm a dad but we were left
wondering why it didn't return the
second she left the aisle black magic
another thing we couldn't help but
notice is that the black magic that we
saw in The Descendants 3 teaser was
nowhere to be found and Janes birthday
cake was never spoiled by it in the
teaser we see our dawn being overtaken
by a powerful force but this never
happened in the movie where's lani Mulan
in leashing daughter Lani made
appearances in both descendants 1 and 2
but for some strange reason she was
nowhere to be found in descendents 3 you
would think that she would be invited to
James birthday party at the very least
did any of you spot lani throughout the
film sound off in the comments the
Knights here's something we still can't
wrap our brains around why will Malin
umma able to beat the Knights and
control their every move
melon Ouma teamed up together to beat
the Knights and they succeeded but why
would their united forces be enough to
overpower Audrey's curse happy birthday
Jane Audrey was clearly upset with Jane
for not inviting her to her birthday
party she cursed everyone putting them
to sleep
but somehow Jane managed to escape
Audrey's clutches and jumped into the
lake unnoticed but why is it that Audrey
didn't see Jane making her grand escape
if you know the answer to this question
tell us in the comments panted Lake the
enchanted water jumping into the
enchanted Lake was all it took for Jane
to escape the sleep spell and squirting
some of that water in Ben's face was
enough to change him from a beast to a
king but if the enchanted water was
really that strong why didn't aim use it
to wake everyone up and why is it that
this water was powerful enough to wash
away Audrey's curse living conditons
beast and bowel must have known that the
kids of the aisle were living in
absolute poverty they had no fruits
supplies candy greenery or abundance of
any kind if fairy godmothers wand is so
powerful why didn't she supply the isle
with enough provisions
Hades amber throughout the movie now
makes it painfully clear that the only
thing strong enough to beat Maleficent
sceptre is Hades ember but during the
film we find out that that's not true
once combines uma and mal can easily
beat audrey spells so why did the V Ches
need the ember in the first place the
barrier now might be a B K but she tends
to put the people of are done before her
very own people now decided to
permanently close the barrier when she
believed Hades or uma to be behind the
supercell so why didn't I change her
mind when she found out that audrey was
the one who stole the crown and the
scepter why did Hades hurt mal Hades
knew that mal was his daughter all along
and the same goes for mal
so why did Hades harm his daughter at
the beginning of the movie that's just
not something a father would do Hades
dreams and mouse powers and put her at
risk only to give her his Ember later on
Audrey's big mistake Audrey almost
succeeded in taking over Aragon and
ruling it once and for all
but those pesky BK's got in her way if
there's one thing we just can't
understand its why Audrey didn't turn
mal to stone when she turns Ben Carlos
jev and dude to stone
don't get the Ember wet hades made it
clear that getting the Ember wet would
ruin it for good
but somehow Mao and Mo were able to
bring it back to life with a simple
spell are we the only ones who thought
that this didn't make sense and now you
will be making your own memories by
doing exactly as I tell you very funny
where's Maleficent we're so happy for
mouth not only did she save our Don and
the Isle but she was also reunited with
her dad it was a happy ending for
everyone well except for a tiny little
lizard named Melissa sent what happened
to her and why didn't now mention her
mouse darkness Disney dissidents
released a teaser trailer called mouths
darkness on March 15th 2019 this trailer
basically told us that Mao was going to
have a vision that showed Aradhana in
ruins but this never happened in the
film which left us with a lot of
questions father-daughter relationship
Mallon Hades never had a relationship
before they met in descendants 3 they
sang about being better off without each
other but by the end of d3 Hades and now
are super close we're all for a happy
ending but now in Hades relationships
seem too good to be true before you go
let us know if you have any answers or
theories that could explain these
unanswered questions sound off in the
comments section and that's a wrap don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching we'll catch you later
[Music]
[Music]